pétion ville est à l'image des autres
villes d'haïti la vie a repris son cours
et chacun tente de gagner son pain comme
il peut l'annoncé de la démission du
premier ministre jacques guy lafon temps
n'a vraisemblablement eu aucun effet sur
le quotidien des milliers d'haïtiens
installé sur un petit bout de trottoir
on a même l'impression que la vie
politique de leur pays ne les intéresse
pas moi c'est les poseurs en question la
démission premier ministre on a pensé
dit ça et on passe une politique non
[Musique]
difficile de les aborder au départ mais
finalement ce sont eux qui émettent
l'envi de nous confier leurs rancoeurs
et des espoirs nous parlait pas achats
de google montanou gbagbo nouvelet ou
moon qui pouvait les coups bas c'est
pour nous bf jouer pour nous jeunes
acteurs l'europe ait possibilité pour
nous car et de petit boulot tout ayed à
marcher et mâcher mais mais mais mais
mais mais non seulement 2 est vrai mais
sans démissionner dans les vosges ne
démissionnait pas d'où venait la soupe
ou voir n'apprend bâton barack obama
toute monnaie à traiter nos wagons avant
président a produit en moi vous nous
mêmes dans les classes sociales un peu
plus aisés le discours sur le
gouvernement reste le même
rien ne va changer dans ce pays et c'est
à dire que peut-être que j'exagère mais
il est évident qu'on vit dans une
situation de désarroi absolue elle a été
créée de toutes pièces
on a tombé dans les égouts dans ce pays
c'est léger coup c'est le règne de
zighoud donc on peut pas prédire ce qui
se passe dans l'échec goût quasi tous
les haïtiens que nous avons rencontrés
sont excédés aucun gouvernement de leur
donne l'espoir d'un jour meilleur
le constat est unanime le président
jouvenet moïse a promis de constituer un
nouveau gouvernement
très vite